[Musique]
temple étranger
[Applaudissements]
nous avons un acte terroriste pour moi
-même,
euh
et je me manque beaucoup
et
[Musique]
deux ans plus tard, c'est
toujours pas pareil tu sais qu'ils ont donné
leur vie
[Musique]
c'est ce que je  je dois être ici parce que mon
fils est là on dirait que ce sera
le cimetière de ma fille
il n'y a pas de mots pour décrire cette douleur
brian green
[musique]
william ralph rob je t'aime papa
nous n'oublierons pas
bien qu'ils soient morts dans la tragédie
ils  n'est pas mort en vain
dans votre chagrin et votre grâce vous nous avez rappelé
qu'ensemble il n'y a rien que nous les
américains ne pouvons pas surmonter les
terroristes ont essayé
de briser
notre résolution ça n'arrivera pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]